[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 5 mars
expliqué les enjeux du patrimoine
d'urbanisme à rambouillet une exposition
joue la carte du ludique avec des
reconstitutions et des jeux le
matrimoine une notion aujourd'hui
inconnue or en rêvant artiste associé à
la ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt
s'intéresse à l'héritage littéraire des
femmes lors d'une conférence le
printemps des poètes sera beau des
balles démarche en musique et en poésie
du 13 au 31 mars ils la 21e édition de
ce printemps rendre ludique les
réglementations urbaine et patrimoniale
rambouillet a choisi d'expliquer ces
l'agrémentation par une exposition
couleurs des bâtiments toiture ou encore
travaux à faire plus belle ma ville
répond aux questions que vous vous posez
peut-être un service d'urbanisme
reconstitué pour expliquer la
réglementation du paysage urbain la
ville de rambouillet joue la carte de
l'exposition donc tout ce qui concerne
le site patrimonial remarquable dès que
vous touchez l'extérieur d'un bâtiment
dans une maison à la façade par exemple
vous devez venir nous rendre visite
qu'on vous explique ce que vous pouvez
ou pas faire et à ce moment là on vous
accompagne avant toute l'instruction de
dossiers avant la délivrance du permis
de construire des jeux ludiques pour
entrer dans un sujet très technique le s
p r site patrimonial remarquable vise à
conserver le patrimoine existant et
l'aspect culturel de la commune cette
exposition elle vise à aider les
administrés à s'accrocher cette
réglementation à leur donner des trucs
pour qu'ils puissent utiliser plus
facilement et à ce que tout le monde
même ceux qui sont pas directement
concernés en comprennent l'intérêt
l'expo vraiment joue la carte de la
scénographie de la mise en scène du
ludique de l'expérimentation et
l'interactivité de façon à ce que tout
le monde puisse rire s'y retrouver et au
mois en repartir avec les idées
principales les équipes on pensait
plusieurs niveaux de lecture pour
répondre à
tous les âges et toutes les questions
une rue fictive a été créé en mêlant
bâti du xviiie début 19e traditionnelle
et une architecture de villégiature fin
du 19ème jusqu'à l'entre-deux-guerres
à vous de deviner qui des boulangers ou
des antiquaires sont les blues élèves
une simple lettre qui change beaucoup de
choses à guyancourt le mardi 12 mars il
sera question du matrimoine et tout
particulièrement de l'héritage
littéraire des femmes une conférence
animée par aurore et 20 en plateau avec
nous ce soir bonjour vous êtes
accompagné du directeur de la ferme de
bel ébat johan lavabre bonjour joue
alors au réveil vous êtes metteuse en
scène au triste chercheuse et comédienne
et votre interrogation sur la place une
ligne dans l'art je crois est assez
ancien oui doit être remonté à peu près
à 20 ans au moins
voilà quand j'étais jeune comédienne et
jeu j'essayais de comprendre pourquoi il
était plus compliqué finalement d'être
autrice metteuse en scène si à l'époque
je ne connaissais pas encore ce motrices
que comédienne et je m'interrogeais sur
cette question la légitimité des femmes
dans le milieu de l'art et de la culture
et notamment d'un des postes de
créatrice de fond statut de créatrices
et donc c'est comme ça que petit à petit
j'ai commencé à dérouler le fil de
l'histoire et du matrimoine et vous
publier des ouvrages en 2001
l'apparition des actrices
professionnelles il ya aussi cinq tomes
de théâtre de fans dans l'ancien régime
vous pousser jusqu'à la recherche
oui voilà oui oui c'était vraiment moi
je commence à être comédienne donc j'ai
commencé à travailler sur l'apparition
des actrices pour justement m'interroger
sur la place de la comédienne dans nos
sociétés qui avaient quand même par
contre elle très légitime
peut-être même trop au point d'effacer
les autres et c'est comme ça qu'en
travaillant sur les premières comédienne
j'ai découvert un beau grand étonnement
que certaines avaient écrit du théâtre
qu'elle avait été joué à l'époque et moi
j'imagine est absolument pas qu'avant le
xxème siècle des femmes et puis écrire
du théâtre être jouer sur des scènes
professionnelles etc
et donc j'ai commencé à tirer ce fil est
à découvrir qu effectivement elles ont
été nombreuses et qu'elles ont plus
connu beaucoup de succès du temps de
boulier
notamment certaines le favori voilà
comme le favori de madame de vidyo une
tragi-comédie qui a été jouée en 1665 y
compris à versailles devant louis xiv
qui a été donc créé à la ferme de bel
ébat théâtre de guyancourt grâce à ioane
nawab ya trois quatre ans et que vous
avez en octobre 2018 18 et qu'on va en
plus reprendre donc un beau parcours
ôter à la cartoucherie au théâtre de
l'épée deux mois au mois de mai du 9 au
19 mai yohan cabaye justement de mettre
les femmes en avant à la ferme de bel
ébat c'était aussi une volonté de
montrer qu'elles sont elles étaient
présentes et elles le sont toujours
vous savez on dit on dit toujours que le
théâtre est le miroir du monde
et force est de constater que il ya un
dysfonctionnement dans ce reflet puisque
les théâtres généralement offre une part
très supérieur aux hommes qu'aux femmes
temps d'antan problème est ancien que
pour l'écriture et donc la ferme de bel
ébat s'est engagé il ya huit ans
maintenant dans un projet de
programmation paritaire on s'évertue à
programmer autant de femmes que d'hommes
tant sur le plan de l'écriture que de la
réalisation des spectacles et il est
évident que la question du matrimoine
s'est posé rapidement dans ce projet de
saison paritaire puisque du coup on
avait du mal à être paritaires quand on
abordait des textes anciens ou quand on
programmait des musiques anciennes et je
me suis rendu compte en rencontrant
aurore et 20
on s'est connus au conseil
d'administration d'à chef ile de france
qui est une association qui lutte pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans les arts et la culture
c'est là que j'ai rencontré aurore et
c'est là que j'ai compris que y compris
dans les oeuvres des anciens temps il y
avait des compositrices il y avait des
autrices et donc on a entamé ce par ce
travail de compagnonnage je vais dire
avec aurore et la ferme de bel ébat pour
mettre en valeur ces femmes là on a
prononcé le mot matrimoine on le précise
ce n'est pas une erreur
le mot existait déjà une petite
explication définition peut-être tout à
fait bien le matrimoine c'est un peu
comme le patrimoine
bien mais les biens culturels hérité des
maires par contre voilà ce n'est pas un
néologisme pas beaucoup d'intérêt à part
les utiliser un néologisme l'intérêt de
ce mot c'est justement qu'il a une
longue histoire et que au moyen âge
quand un couple se mariait il déclaré à
la fois son patrimoine et son patrimoine
est souvent voilà pour résumer en
faisant une petite pirouette je dis
souvent à la fin il n'est plus resté que
les journées européennes du patrimoine
et les agences matrimoniales donc on
voit très bien comment voilà le destin
de ces deux mots résument aussi la place
des femmes dans la dans notre histoire
culturelle et notre histoire littéraire
justement de nombreuses femmes ont été
rendues invisibles on connaît tous plus
ou moins george sand qui signait sous
une un nom d'homme fred vargas qui
ferait d'étain le des notices de son
prénom mais a une consonance masculine
aussi où on en connaît beaucoup des
femmes comme cinq ans et qui sont passés
un peu à la trappe dans l'histoire
énormément et on en découvre en fait
presque tous les jours c'est ça qui est
étonnant c'est que très longtemps moi
quand j'ai commencé ce que j'expliquais
tout à l'heure on pensait qu
effectivement nous n'avons femme n'avait
pas d'histoire finalement et parce que
l'histoire a été écrite uniquement en
gardant que les hommes
et quand on commence à creuser en ces
vrais faux travail d'archéologue
eh ben on s'aperçoit qu'en fait elles
sont très nombreuses 1 voilà et que
composent dans la musique dans la
peinture dans l'écriture dans les
sciences également donc
donc il ya bien une histoire et elle est
très importante et l'a donc cette
conférence du 12 mars
quelle est-elle quel est le but que ce
que vous voulez montrer au public
le but c'est justement de prouver qu'il
existe effectivement un héritage parce
que moi je préfère parler d'héritage qui
est constitué à la fois de patrimoine et
de matrimoine voilà qu'il y à des femmes
qui peuvent être nous servir également
de modèle que les hommes peuvent se
trouver également filiation avec des
figures féminines
voilà donc qui sait tout ça c'est aussi
une question de légitimité pour les
jeunes femmes aussi de savoir que non il
ya les femmes ont eu des capacités pour
écrire pour faire là pour peindre et
c'est donc c'est de raconter un peu
cette histoire leur match par du théâtre
parce que c'est de là je viens de leur
univers mais ça peut se décliner
exactement de la même façon pour la
musique la peinture les beaux-arts et
c'est donc donc je raconte moi mon ma
découverte de ce matrimoine théâtrale et
comment il a été effacé et quel est
l'intérêt aujourd'hui de le rendre à
nouveau visible et même de le remettre
en performance parce que ça c'est aussi
une question très importante
une performance que justement la ferme
de bel ébat ne va pas s'arrêter à 2019
2018 2019
vous aller encore plus loin ça va durer
quatre ans matrimoine sert projet ce
projet qui s'appelle édifier notre
matrimoine c'est un projet soutenu par
le ministère de la culture la drac d'île
de france et la région ile de france
oui est un programme qu'on a établi avec
aurore sur quatre ans donc il ya
beaucoup de choses et on travaille
également ensemble à la création d'un
réseau coopératif national de production
afin de fédérer un certain nombre de
théâtre sur tout le territoire pour
pouvoir aider la création de ce
spectacle qui s'est pas facile c'est les
moyens de production souhait c'est qu'il
ya dans la culture un certain frein
peut-être de là produits de producteurs
de même du public aussi il ya un an il
ya un frein à produire parce que les on
va dire que l'argent va aux plus riches
en fin de prêt de corrige comme on dit
donc voilà c'est assez facile de
produire le théâtre classique c'est
compliqué parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnages donc ça coûte assez cher
bon néanmoins on arrive à monter du
shakespeare du molière dire assez
facilement dans le réseau théâtrale par
contre sur le nom de ses hôtes rice
elles ont elles ont le handicap d'être
des classiques mais non reconnu et donc
ne pas avoir cet effet d'appel vis-à-vis
du public
mais voilà il ne tient qu'à nous de le
corriger on s'y emploie
et justement pour le corriger une
première étape le mardi 12 mars merci à
tous les deux d'être venu sur ce plateau
l'agenda sa fiche
c'est à la médiathèque jean rousselot et
la réservation est conseillée là aussi
tout est affiché
la statue du château de plaisir dévoile
ses mystères dans le cadre de la
réhabilitation du parc du château
la municipalité a décidé de lui offrir
une seconde jeunesse le reportage est
signée marie lenga pichoff musique ou
monde pour accompagner sa concentration
autour des quatre éléments
depuis deux semaines dédiées matar
constituent les parties manquantes de
cette mystérieuse statut ils sont
arrivés un peu dans ces cas là
à l'atelier donc on a vraiment un état
sanitaire qui est vraiment très dégradée
avec des parties manquantes sur les mes
genoux les jambes les têtes sur la
partie haute
le sculpteur a tout de suite été surpris
par la qualité de l'oeuvre des détails
soignés et un style propre 18e qui n'est
pas sans rappeler les sculptures du
château de versailles
cette torsion qui tourne c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
une magnifique sculpture son nom reste
tout aussi inconnu que celui de son
auteur
elles représentent les quatre éléments
l'eau la terre le feu et l'air
ce sont les deux personnages qui ont les
ailes ceux du bas n'ont pas d'elle donc
là on me tend le bras en l'air de 20 ans
à atteindre l'air pour redonner la
beauté de ces détails-là la statue
dédiée matar commence par créer une
forme en terre pour ensuite faire un
moulage en plâtre
une fois ce moulage parfait il sera
copié en pierre est posée sur la statue
tout ça ça n'existait pas on essaye
d'intégrer vraiment notre travail ou
patrimoine passé sans essayer de deux
d'inventer les choses on essaye vraiment
de respecter au maximum la sculpture
une fois terminée cette statue des
quatre éléments se retrouvera ici son
socle est déjà prêt à l'accueillir une
touche finale à la réhabilitation du
parc du château
nous sommes très fiers d'avoir une
oeuvre comme celle là dans le parc du
château
puisque ça ne fait que compléter
l'ensemble de ce que nous avons voulu
faire depuis de nombreuses années
château et statues se feront face de
vieux amis qui retrouveront chacun leur
tour les traits de leur jeunesse le
printemps sera beau c'est en tout cas la
couleur que les utilitaires poétique et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines veulent donner
à son 21e printemps des poètes
jacques fourni jours bonsoir en tant que
directeur d est une erreur politique qui
comment vous avez pensé cette édition
dont s'est emparé du teil nationale la
beauté et puis je me suis dit mais
pourquoi la beauté c'est un petit peu
bateau c'est un peu obsolète peut-être
comme image c'est un thème qui a été
énormément abordé au 19e siècle
on connaît le travail de baudelaire
autour de la beauté de la laideur donc
j'ai intitulé notre printemps des poètes
très vite la beauté est alors que faire
de ça et donc on l'a décliné mais en
même temps c'est un thème qui n'en est
pas un on se moque un peu
on emprunte tous les chemins qu'on peut
emprunter qu'on veut emprunter sur ce
territoire pour faire en sorte que la
poésie qu'elle évoque ou non la beauté
soit présenté au public
c'est très utile comme notion à la
beauté ça peut parler à tourner comme
tout
vous allez faire des lectures des jeux
d'écriture des expositions comme
toujours il y en a pour tous les goûts
oui on essaie on essaye de faire en
sorte que tout le monde se sente un jour
ou l'autre concernés par la poésie c'est
mon cheval de bataille depuis depuis
quelques décennies quand même maintenant
et je suis moi persuadé qu'on a tous
quelque chose à voir avec la poésie à un
moment ou à un autre de notre vie même
si le but n'est pas d'attirer des
centaines de milliers de personnes à
venir écouter un poète devant son micro
non non c'est à dire qu'à un moment ou
un autre que ça soit dans un bus que ce
soit à l'occasion d'une manifestation un
peu atypique d'une marche comme on va
organiser trois marches poétique et
musical cette année que les gens se
disent bah ouais tiens ça ça me parle ça
ça me dit quelque chose ça me concerne
et à partir du moment où il ya un écho
en soi inévitablement
on ne voit pas le monde de la même
manière et ça c'est une bonne chose
parce que dans ce printemps des poètes
les poètes viennent qu'au public
oui les poètes reviennent au public on
va on va chez l'habitant puisqu'on à une
rencontre avec le poète série de mohamed
et le guitariste de jazz charles barkat
chez des habitants attrape le 15 le 15
mars
on est dans l'est dans les bus de saint
quentin en yvelines grâce à ski bus et
pour les embuscades avec le collectif
les profs d'histoire ce sont des pots
des comédiens et des comédiennes qui
vivent à travers la poésie avec leur
meneur de jeu avec sandwichs x est un
vrai bonheur à chaque fois voilà on
essaye de faire en sorte que voilà les
poètes et notion de trois marches on
aura des poètes et des comédiens et des
musiciens qui diront qu'ils iront qui
interviendront et on aura encore aussi
et ça j'y tiens tous les ans et les
médiathécaires sont très réactifs
on aura des interventions dans les
médiathèques deux après midi de mercredi
le 13 et le 20 mars avec les poètes
thierry casals et yves godin et les
musiciens olivier journaux qui est un
musicien du territoire et voilà et du
conservatoire de trappes et ils seront
là pour donner à entendre aussi des
poèmes et aussi pour faire écrire et
puis animé une scène ouverte où chacun à
une heure donnée pourra venir s'emparer
du micro pour dire un texte de son choix
de lui ou de quelqu'un d'autre
il n'y a pas de regard critique il ya
tout simplement le plaisir d'entendre un
les nouveautés cette année on parle d
une des nouveautés mais sait-on part à
la toute fin on les tue printemps oui
les 30 et 31 mars
il y a le premier village du mot oui ça
c'est une envie que l'on a eues avec les
médiathèques de d'offrir un événement
qui soit pas un salon du livre
et qui soit un temps à la fois culturel
et ludique partage est ouvert à tous
dans un lieu que l'on veut que l'on
souhaite ouvert à tous et la commanderie
à elancourt où nous sommes installés
depuis septembre avec l'atelier des
sciences les arts visuels et la mission
denses et donc on va investir la
médialle à la commanderie
pendant deux après midi avec des
ateliers ouverts des ateliers de
calligraphie mais aussi d'écriture de
bulles de bandes dessinées avec une
bédéiste bab et de dessins de mots avec
henri wagner le retour puisque henry
était intervenu à la maison de la poésie
il ya quelques quelques années avec des
conférences mais à la fois des
conférences tresses on va dire très
sérieuse sur les problèmes de langage la
naissance du langage dans l'ail et des
orthophonistes qui seront présentes sur
la langue des signes
on a déjà eu l'occasion de travailler
brigitte bomy en févrie en auvent en
décembre pardon à plaisir mais aussi
d'aider des conférences un peu
différente sur les mots de l'oulipo de
l'ouvroir de littérature potentielle qui
avaient décalé et créée par raymond
queneau et le lyonnais en 1960 et hélas
c'est son plus jeune représentant
frédéric forte qui viendra nous parler
de l'oulipo on aura aussi une dictée
parce qu'une une fête du mot sur la
dictée pour moi c'est inconcevable donc
une dictée qu'il sera créé dit corrigés
et commentés par julien soulié qui est
un grand spécialiste de l'orthographe
il faut réviser un petit peu avant la
réviser faut sortir sont grévistes il
faut sortir son bled et puis il faut il
faut s'y mettre
d'une façon très sérieuse mais il ya
suffisamment de sites internet qui
permettent de corriger ses propres
fautes quand on parle et quand on écrit
aussi voilà et donc ça on l'a voulu et
on a surtout voulu que tout les services
culturels de saint quentin en yvelines
soit impliqué c'est à dire chacun
apporté il y aura une conférence sur les
mots de la ville par des représentants
du musée de la ville il y aura une
intervention d'une compagnie de danse
proposé par la mission danse
il y aura conférence par l'atelier des
sciences et il y aura aussi donc
l'intervention d'henri wagner grâce aux
arts visuels
on a voulu quelque chose qui soit commun
dans ce lieu qui est ouvert à tous il
s'appelle la commanderie et qui doit
être animée par tous dans un projet
commun et donc ça c'est une des
occasions qu'on a cette année de pouvoir
proposer quelque chose
tout le monde se mêlent pour proposer
pour tous les publics tous les habitants
les jeunes les plus jeunes les moins
jeunes
voilà il ya la place pour tout le monde
et ça va être très ludique et on
l'espère et cette année vous avez une
marraine
oui on est cinquième rapport c'était
quelques jours c'est moins ça mais vous
avez une invitée d'honneur comme chaque
année cette année votre choix s'est
porté sur claudine boeing doit être
parisienne pourquoi elle après une
algérienne samira negrouche une
québécoise nicole brossard j'ai souhaité
inviter claudine bories
ça fait un an que je l'invité elle était
venue ne le rencontre il y a un an et je
lui dis ben tu sera l'invité d'honneur
de 2019 m'a dit oui tout de suite
voilà pourquoi elle parce que c'est une
belle personne que j'aime profondément
la personne et j'aime l'écriture de la
personne c'est une des écritures les
plus les plus ciselée qui soit
actuellement dans la littérature de
langue française c'est une poète qui
publie régulièrement chez différents
petits éditeurs et qui est très peu
visible parce qu'elle ne veut pas être
visible une grande timide et là quand je
vais me reposer
voilà elle se cache derrière elle se
fait sûrement un petit peu violence
parce que je vais proposer une carte
blanche qu'elle animera avec ses invités
poète et musicien et il y aura cinq six
rencontres avec elle elle remettra elle
a été présidente du pri du crous à
l'université elle aura une rencontre
avec éric chat se fier à la librairie
mille feuilles
elle fera l'ouverture du printemps des
poètes avec lucienne deschamps et ses
musiciens le 13 mars donc à 20h à
plaisir au théâtre aubert manuel et je
remercie la ville de plaisir de nous
proposer de nous permettre de faire cela
au théâtre voilà et donc c'est une
personne que j'aime profondément et qui
a un regard très intelligent sans être
intellectuel sur l'écriture sur la
poésie sur le rôle du poids devrait vous
lire un extrait d'un entretien qu'il a
eu avec très rapidement très rapidement
ce qui me fait tenir debout dans une
société mécanisée recouverte
d'automatismes qui nous empêche de
penser de rêver sauf de manière encadrée
c'est l'importance de rendre à chacun
son imagination et sa place pas
uniquement sociales dans le monde et je
crois que ça c'est vraiment le rôle de
la poésie de rendre à chacun sa place
dans le monde
et c'est sur ces mots que on va se
quitter merci on le rappelle le
printemps des poètes débute le 13 mars
prochain pour ne rien rater du
rendez-vous kiosque pointe ce qu'il
voulait faire
nono quatre lettres bien connu des saint
quentinois amateurs d'improvisation
noureev inouïe c'est son nom est tombé
dans le théâtre tout petit il a une
multitude de casquettes pour un
passionné nous nous consacrons un
portrait ce 24 janvier l'heure est à
l'installation comme chaque année les
équipes de déclic théâtre investissent
les collèges saint quentinois
le match d'aujourd'hui c'est très
important de savoir c'est un match
amical on est bien d'accord
l'équipe qui gagne et qui perd on s'en
fiche il y a le collège gustave courbet
attrape celui des débuts de noureev
chine luis plus connu sous le nom de no
no 92 une premier match d'impro et puis
courbet c'est aussi le collège ou ou aux
baous djamel notamment il ça on commence
l improvisation et puis plein d'autres
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui des grandes
stars du showbiz mais en tout cas
beaucoup de comédiens ou de techniciens
même je pense à hocine à marion qui
étaient là avec nous on a tous eu nos
pour beaucoup on a fait nos premiers pas
ici à courbot aussi cmit nono joue
souvent larbitre celui qui donne les
thèmes et distribuer les pénalités le
méchant en apparence sympa à l'ecoute
joyeux toujours jamais ni les îles et
les gentils quand on est quand on est
sur scène fin il fait l arbitre qui est
méchant mais en vrai avec nous quand
en dessous la patinoire il nous donne
des conseils celui qui le découvre c'est
le fondateur de déclic théâtre papy lors
d'un atelier au collège on dit donc
c'est pas mal hein faut inscrire le
mercredi est inscrit sur les ateliers du
midi donc l'année commencé moi je
m'inscris pas je finis mon module je
suis mon année comme ça et puis en
cinquième j'ai retourné je m'inscris le
midi entre midi et deux pour faire d'un
pro mais très sincèrement plus pour
faire plaisir à papa
une première année où ils s'estiment
insignifiant puis un déclic avec le
départ des plus grands un goût de faire
rire de la scène rejoint par une envie
de transmettre papim dit un atelier la
croix du bois pour les jeunes de voisins
machin et tout ac à venir ok donc moi je
suis à l'heure et il y a
vingtaine de jeunes qui sont là et
papy ne vient pas enfin pas pu bien par
papier pas là à l'heure prévue et au
bout de trois quarts d'heure papy qui
avait une galère sur la route papier
arrive et moi en fait je le regarde je
dis c'est bon ils sont chauds et
d'innocents continue
donc je dis ah bon yoav ziv asie je te
regarde
non mais là lors des ateliers s'occupe
du secteur improvisation il est aussi
directeur artistique des créations de la
troupe déclic et metteur en scène d'un
seul en selle le premier d'antoine rabot
lui aussi formé attrape un truc où tu
vois tu as un geste physique comme quand
on ferme les impros en quintet quoi tu
vois quelque chose qui vient pas
perturber par le déplacement le 2 mars
prochain antoine montera sur scène au
guichet montparnasse pour 1h
d'improvisation c'est un très grand
pédagogue de ce que je connais c'est ça
doit être un des meilleurs profs d'un
projet j'ai pu avoir jusqu'à la m6
arbitre responsable de l'improvisation
comédien metteur en scène nono multiplie
les casquettes avec toujours un objectif
transmettre son amour de la scène
[Musique]
ils chantent dansent amusé grimace
jovani raconte avec humour comment il
est devenu un artiste il est sur la
scène de la royale factory de versailles
les 8 et 9 mars prochains
c'est une première averse à et la ville
accueille la 3ème édition de vinexpo
pendant deux jours les professionnels
les amateurs et les passionnés vont se
rencontrer à l'hôtel de ville pour y
trouver collector pressage rares ou
encore objets décoratifs et marylène à
iapichino reçoit l'organisatrice de
cette édition dans son 7,8 me dire du
jeu 17 mars
s'ils me provient aussi pour coignard le
21 juin prochain la ville organisera sa
première fête de la musique pour
l'occasion un appel à candidature est
lancé musiciens et chanteurs sont
sollicités pour un concert acoustique et
les clayes-sous-bois recherche elle des
candidats pour sa nouvelle édition du
festival du court métrage vous avez
jusqu'au 21 ans pour candidater une
festival aura lieu lui le samedi 1er
juin marion pellissier s'est inspiré des
prisons autogéré et des émissions de
télé réalité dans les petites villes
artiste associé au théâtre de saint
quentin en yvelines raconte l'histoire
de filles enfermées dans ce qui pourrait
être une prison à découvrir les 12 et 13
mars
mireille hakima et astrid ont été élues
boudin de l'année de ce postulat
dégradant elle s'en fout une force en
tentant de réaliser un projet
s'incruster à la garden party de
l'elysée regarder tes parents sont
d'accord pour te laisser est comme ça à
12 ans sur les routes de france va
verser les forêts les montagnes mes
parents
beaucoup l'afrique ces jours 5 nuits
ardeurs doucet maire de pédalage par
jour ça va se faire c'est comme un repas
par ailleurs deux fils et un verbe la
pétanque du temps c'est bien d'avoir
indochine accord signé par whaou sais
pas ce qui s'est passé mais d'un coup
tous vos intérêts tant attendu de
maturité surprenante votre âge pourquoi
ils la voyaient arriver rires c'est la
fin de ce set une culture merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
oh